[Music]
good morning John it's Wednesday August
29th the day you died was a good day you
said that it was better than Oprah's
best birthday but instead of having
awake lots and lots of people a blended
birthday cake so good bachelor nine year
old John you should be proud of the
awards you won those silver is not as
good as gold oh my god you're 30 years
old well you started out obsessed with a
Frank and lonely girl but then you
decided to jump into their world and
somehow you dragged your brother and it
with you and started this thing that we
call Brotherhood - Oh goodbye 29
year-old John you should be proud of the
awards you won the silver is not as good
as gold oh my god you thirty years old
well your I got infected and it
threatened to explode you found yourself
a yard that needed to be mowed and you
got yourself a house and you got
yourself a weed and you and the Yeti had
your first anniversary Oh goodbye 29
year old John you should be proud of the
boards you on the silver is not as good
as gold
oh my god you thirty years old
I got you're 30 years old oh my captain
30 years old oh my god you're 30 years
old no guitar so I decided to play the
drums on the nearest book nerdfighters
should be very excited about tomorrow
that was on the top of barbecue sauce
weird thing about this copy of peeps is
that it's signed by Scott Westerfeld but
- are soo cute sister Maureen it's
really good I like that I brought like
100 pages of it last night between like
2:00 and 4:00 in the morning so yeah my
sleep schedule is a little screwed up
John I'll see you very shortly
and I'll see you on YouTube tomorrow